father when can i leave to be on my own
he doesn't move like he's man out of
wood
it's it's fully 2d animation no 3d at
all so so where does cg have trouble
versus 2d have trouble in your opinion
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end so you can
find out how to get 15 off your raycon
purchase
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of animators react we are here
on the couch alex snow and we did some
episodes with alex in the past alex is a
very accomplished animator he's been
working on a bunch of stuff what are we
gonna be looking at today i brought a
bunch of clips both cg and 2d let's do
it let's jump in
let's go
so we're gonna take a look at klaus
which is awesome if you guys haven't
seen a good christmas movie in a while
klaus you definitely need to check out
the origin of santa claus it's like
batman but it's santa claus so you're
saying this is like batman begins for
santa this is batman begins for santa
this is santa starts santa starts yeah
santa starts but it wasn't
working
it looks like 2d animation right
but the shading is like way beyond
anything like there's textures that are
like stuck to the surfaces see the
highlight on her hair as she leaves the
sort of sun beam there it's like you got
this nice soft lighting on her hair that
then slowly sort of fades back behind
her head just to pull the curtain back
it's it's fully 2d animation no 3d at
all there are some 3d elements but as
far as character animation it is fully
2d animation for all the characters with
some props and things that are cg this
is kind of reminding me of the first
space jam movie where they went through
and they did the classic you know layer
of animation but then they went back and
did a shading pass where they really try
to add not just the shadows but the
highlights to really make it feel more
three-dimensional space jam is probably
one of the best examples of kind of that
like volumetric lighting but every high
quality 2d animation has highlights and
shadow passes so with klaus the thing
about the lighting is they're basically
using technology to track the highlights
and things like that and there's like a
lighting team making very specific
artistic choices you're still having to
babysit it and you know make those
choices and make sure your frame is the
way you want it at the end of the day so
it's kind of combining the old way of
highlights and cleanup and using
technology to aid with that but also aid
it with more details so modern
rotoscoping a lot of it is just doing a
shape with points and you just move
those points the shape will adapt so it
looks like they're really just
leveraging that technology and then
using of course the lines in their
layers to basically punch out these
areas and just let those masks move and
you just follow the hand animation and
you kind of you're doing the lighting by
hand still but you're relying on the
computer to push those lines
frame by frame so you can kind of just
do the overall appearance and i bet you
you can also like there's some
intelligent stuff in there it's kind of
pinning itself 100 layers a little bit i
definitely think they're using some like
tracking tech you kind of create this
mask and then you're adjusting it how
you need but also the computer's helping
you we actually do we do very similar
read lighting with a lot of our visual
effects actually where like you'll have
a person and like okay i need like
there's a muzzle flash or an explosion i
need like some light to hit them and
you'll just you'll go in and you'll draw
the light in by hand you're not taking a
paint brush in photoshop and painting it
you're carving out an area with your
spline paths and then you're just
animating that every couple of frames to
like track until it's done it seems like
they're basically just doing the same
thing here so alex can you talk about
how they incorporate 3d elements into 2d
animation it's just like a super
advanced version of where 2d animation
was kind of headed back when it kind of
stopped on a feature level change
we move now treasure planet was breaking
into all new things they animated
roughly an arm for the captain and then
they replaced it with cg as like a robot
arm it was headed towards using cg in a
way that would advance the medium
without taking away from the artistry
and the 2d understanding that they had
built for the last 80 years viewers
might be wondering why an object would
be done in 3d versus hand drawn in a
movie as hand-drawn my observation is
that basically anytime you're dealing
with an object that's like a
geometrically kind of complex shape
that's not squashing or squishing or
talking or moving that's something where
if you do that as a 3d object you can
just kind of cell shade it it just makes
it really easy when that object's just
there but just changing perspective so
like all the food on the tray like that
food isn't talking or dancing it's just
sitting there and so she picks up the
trade now you have to as an artist you
have to go in you have to draw perfect
perspective shifts on all these
geometric shapes as it gets carried
around this is actually something that i
believe uh japanese animators were known
for doing really well yeah back in the
day with original gundam cartoons yeah
they do perfect draft drawings these
robots as a perspective would shift it'd
all just be flawless yeah but these days
you can do that kind of thing in cg you
can still do your characters hand-drawn
but if you have like a truck or a car
you see us in the simpsons or futurama
like the cars are just a shape and just
the shape moves perspective wise and
that's it yeah the hardest part is then
like melding it back into the 2d space
[Music]
another thing i'm noticing here i think
it's important to note that even though
you know most of this is not computer
generated it is still going through a 3d
process i imagine like the foreground
layers are being exported out as
separate layers that are then having an
optical pass applied to it such as depth
of field notice how the actual depth of
field is getting blurrier as it gets
closer to camera and that you know that
focus plane is changing and i was
noticing this earlier too where you have
a character who's out of focus in the
foreground and i'm pretty sure that's a
computer computer-generated
focus effect happening you know it's
very difficult to intentionally paint or
draw something out of focus and that is
where the 3d aspect of using computers
you can really leverage 100 of that so
where does cg have trouble versus 2d
have trouble in your opinion the
computer is made to make realistic stuff
there's advantages to this with lighting
and texture tracking and so then it
becomes how do we fight the plastic feel
of sid from toy story or even worse the
baby from toy story there's certain
things that need rigidity there's
certain things that need to be broken
where you start to lean more into the
artistic look that isn't necessarily
replicating reality but being influenced
by reality in the same way a painting is
like one of the more successful ones i
think disney's done is feast this like
feast is doing that i think probably the
best that we've ever seen a major studio
do up until maybe arcane and arguably
this looks nothing like arcane you know
this is a very different look it's just
interesting as everyone's kind of taking
different approaches to stop motion to
2d to 3d literally every form of
animation right now is going through
this growth and evolution where it wants
to stand out it wants to be unique and
as amazing and pop off the screen as
much as concept art pops off the page
hey you get over here so bad guys is
kind of just in the same scope as what
we've been talking about this is
dreamworks's latest film and they've
kind of shifted away from their old
stuff kind of shifted into pushing that
style you know matching their concept
art to some degree and it's just really
interesting to see something that's
pushing away from that generic cg style
and look but doing in a way that's so
different than other stuff we've seen
today
you get the hand-drawn effects in there
yeah i'm getting slight like mitchell
versus the machine vibes here too yeah
mitchell's is another great example of
it's doing a lot of 2d animation in
addition to it but what they're doing in
like the face what you can see like the
teeth are changing dependent it's doing
a lot of things you see like that little
ring around his pupil
on that shot the black outlines on his
eyes yeah lines on his cheeks and yeah
you'll see blush lines on the characters
sometimes there's just a lot of cool
things they're doing but even with their
movement the posing you know you see a
lot of this in pixar's latest film
turning red and a little bit in luca as
well so you're just seeing that
influence kind of flow through so many
movies right now yeah i didn't do much
work on bad guys but even the little bit
i was on was was super fun and just
being able to play with these characters
was so cool i'm just wondering how the
animator had to tackle that scene where
the snake plays the guitar
ropes are not great in cg and snakes
aren't too much better but they had a
cool rig on on snake i used it
completely wrong
on my shot and halfway through i was
like oh that's how you're supposed to
use it but you know even with that i was
able to get what i needed it was pretty
creative and the things people did with
him you know even just like the break in
his neck you see this in like art
lessons and stuff like straights verse
curves and and things like that so like
an arm like this you'd want the straight
here and then flowy on the other side
same with like a leg so you feel that
knee but you feel the like thigh and the
calf it kind of creates this nice
balance of of straights and curves and
so it's hard to do when you have
something that bends with a rig that's
trying to weight that difference and
keep that volume and to make something
like
really straight or rigid even like a
back of a head you do that with a pencil
you just go oh okay
back in his head is stylized but yeah
for snake getting those breaks in his
neck depending on the camera and the
performance and moving in and out of
those is you know a lot of work that you
don't really realize till you're doing
it
hey everybody i need i need some
comments here i need some suggestions
you know there's those cheap kids shows
cartoons what's the one scene we're like
that was crazy blew my mind i would love
those suggestions
i kind of feel like we should look at
james lee's stuff next actually so james
lee's been doing animations for years he
like started way back in the early new
ground stage oh nice here's an animator
that's so good at posing he does it
himself with stop motion in his body and
blends it with hand
this animation right here he does
[Laughter]
how he's moving and posing is very
similar to like how you would animate an
[Music]
and
anime
to me
well that's crazy oh wait was that a
warping himself i think that's a warp
but everything is so like
perfectly smooth yeah he's so good at
this style you see it once in a while
it's very subtle but he'll change the
shape of his glasses to match his
expressions that's cool oh you're right
it's subtle it gets a little bit like
yeah
yeah that's one of the most annoying
things is characters with big glasses
that don't change because their brows
are always i didn't realize that that's
really funny and some characters are
just you have to crank the eyebrows up
so high
to see them or so low to see them that
you don't get the the feeling you want
unless the glasses happen to be like his
the shape like he's mainly evil but like
the relationship between the brow and
the pupil specifically is so important
for selling how you feel you know and
that compression so in the face it's
it's like a whole another body right so
everything is affecting each other if
you look up your your eyelids are going
to usually stay
peaked where your eyeball is looking so
you have to understand what's leading
what and how that can change the emotion
the expression when you smile for real
the corners of your mouth push up your
cheeks and your cheeks push up your
lower lids so you're seeing this
compression on the lower half and even
if i'm not even happy it seems like i'm
happier than i was when i was just
smiling just by compressing those eyes
so yeah you know like the thing that i
find really cool is like he's fully
understood like poses and like he'll
really be frozen
and it'll just be like three or four
frames like yeah different pose he's a
very dark character how his pose is red
via the background compared to his you
know pose is super important because if
his hand is in shadow and his chest is
in shadow all of a sudden his hands are
gone so if it's doing anything
interesting you're not gonna see it so
like him bringing his hand out into the
silhouette of his body and clearing that
i mean even when he hits the pose like
he's sticking out he has like a little
bit of backlight hitting his bottom lips
yeah it's not just lost in the
silhouette of his face yeah this is
there's so much effort going into every
single shot here
[Music]
oh my god this is just like meme city
going on
[Music]
this is like one of those things where
like it doesn't matter how good or bad
it is it has all of like the intent of
just being wild yeah it's worth looking
at just because this is how you animate
when you start as much as this was
probably done uh definitely just for
laughs and for you know how much time do
you really want to spend on it honestly
we don't start with something dissimilar
to this when we start in cg animation
pipeline because it goes from
storyboards then you have to figure out
how to make that
in space and then generally speaking at
most studios you'll get something like
this you'll delete the animation and
then you'll kind of use that basic
positioning as your starting point and
then you build there's no reason this
animation couldn't be awesome it's just
this artist obviously there's no reason
for them to yeah you can get a lot of
diminishing returns on the refinement
but here i think the lack of refinement
is part of the point to continue this
trend here's another clip
there you go now what should we name you
pinocchio this you almost have to hear
with the dialogue
father when can i leave to be on my own
[Laughter]
this is a real movie a real trailer that
he does a lot of backflips
you know he doesn't move like he's man
or would something we did on oz the
great and powerful was the china girl
you know making her feel fragile and
shaky and we do the same thing with olaf
like he can't bend his stick arms
because they're made of sticks so this
to me he's not animated like he's would
at all he's just animated like anyone
else he's just anything like a boy yeah
you skipped the whole like your puppet
part unfortunately everyone else is
animated just as it would in like so
and to be fair i'm sure they had a tight
time and budget and everything like
always but there's little things that
you can choose to do that have nothing
to do with that like even that quick
shot of the horse's hooves landing the
fact that they're all like this
perfectly in line with each other right
there
like there's no imperfections of the
foot turned out or depth being thought
of of the feet landing at different
times there's no texture in it meaning
visual movement texture built in it's
just very rigid and stiff the posing is
very twinned meaning the same on each
side exactly not not any kind of
asymmetry there's just so many things
you could spend the same amount of time
no like you're something like you're
opening up like my eyes this it's like
okay like you know put some vibration to
the feet like have one turned outwards
and like yeah you know break the
continuity break the symmetry yeah it's
really the same concept as what we were
talking about it's just like the
imperfections are what sells the
believability when everything is very
perfect
not that that's perfect but it feels
computer generated it feels out of the
box it doesn't have the life or the
believability built in even if you're
looking at like paw patrol there's
thought going behind the poses it's
something like hotel transylvania it
takes a lot longer to get your key poses
because you literally have to sculpt
some of those for the shot break the rig
use a lattice deformer use all sorts of
tweaks and and twists but you you're
making up for that time by snapping from
post to pose so you don't have to live
within it or you can get out of it
seamlessly without slowly undoing that
warped brokenness so you can hide it the
cinematography is a thing that stands
out to me here too like there's some
shots that are afraid to find there's a
lot of shots that aren't really framed
that great for what's going on it takes
just as much time to put your camera
here as it does here right that shot
could have been framed better and taken
the exact same amount of time to make
something i see in cg especially with
like demo reels and and people's work is
the locked off camera it's an emotional
shot you want that camera to slowly go
in and and bring you into the character
and what they're dealing with that's two
key frames yeah camera and people don't
do it i mean look at the locked off
shots are in this exactly it's it's
there's no thought behind it the
cinematography like good storyboards and
good music you're already feeling what
you're going to feel in the finished
film and if you're not you're fighting
it the whole time it's weird also seeing
like this rendered like without ambient
occlusion without like yeah i mean klaus
had subsurface scattering and this
doesn't
what's up guys i'm jordan and today i'm
going to be talking to you about raycon
today's sponsor
raycon's everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever they fit perfect
in the air because of their optimized
gel tips they're so comfortable and they
will not budge trust me raycons are
priced just right you get quality audio
at half the price of other premium audio
brands
they offer eight hours of play time and
also 32 hour battery life i can just
take it out my ear
pop it right on in the case and close it
and it starts charging immediately it's
so convenient no wonder raycon's
everyday earbuds have over 49 thousand
five star reviews i do wear these
earbuds around the studio but the
perfect thing about them is i can still
hear my co-workers while i'm doing my
stuff but if i want to hone in and focus
and do something just on my own i can
turn on the isolation mode and i won't
hear anything around me
i could keep talking about raycon all
day but i think it's time that you go
find out about them on your own so click
that link or go to buyreicon.com quarter
crew so you can get 15 off of your own
pair of raycons let me know what color
you choose
alex thank you so much for coming on the
show today this was a huge blast to
shoot with you i can't wait to have you
on the show again next time yeah
absolutely it's always fun coming and
and i would absolutely love to come back
you can find alex on instagram at
snowmation plus double plus productions
both on instagram check it out and in
the
thingy
there's links down below of course you
know how to do this there's also this
like little notification bell you can
hit when you hit that subscribe you look
right here there's a bunch more videos
you can watch it's like a whole website
and everything
thank you so much for watching everybody
we'll see you guys in the next one